même bonjour alors nous sommes avec vous
merci d'être avec moi est ce que c'est
une décision surprenante celle que nous
venons d'apprendre oui bien sûr c'est
une décision extrêmement surprenante
dans la mesure où des experts
psychiatriques de renom ont alerté et
continue d'alerter sur la santé physique
et mentale de julian assange vous savez
que c'est sur ce point principalement
que les états unis ont fait appel ils
ont profité d'une toute petite brèche
pour gagner en appel ils ont pointé le
fait qu'un expert psychiatre michael
kopelman qui est chef du service de
neuro psychiatriques au king's collège
de londres qui avait pointé en septembre
2020 le risque très élevé de suicides
d'assange en cas d'extradition il aurait
selon les états unis je cite tromper la
justice en dissimulant que son patient
était devenu père alors qu'ils étaient
cloîtrés à l'ambassade d'équateur à
londres vous savez que tous les bassins
ya eu deux enfants avec son avocate et
compagnes stèle à maurice pendant qu'il
était réfugié à l'ambassade d'équateur
donc comme il n'a pas donné cette
information est bien qu'on peut
qualifier d'ailleurs d'un team alors les
états unis ont tout fait pour
décrédibiliser l'ensemble du témoignage
de son neuro psychiatre alors on imagine
bien évidemment qu'il ya dû avoir
beaucoup de réactions du côté de ses
proches bien sûr du côté de ses proches
c'est évidemment la consternation est
une immense déception d'abord pour sa
famille sa compagne c'était là maurice
qui est aussi son avocate je les dis a
qualifié cette décision de grave erreur
judiciaire comment je la cite comment
peut-il être honnête comment peut-il
être juste comment peut-il être possible
d'extrader julian dans le pays même qui
a comploté pour le tuer at elle demandé
en référence à de récentes révélations
sur des projets d'assassinât de julian
assange par la cia c'est une souffrance
est une immense déception a également
déclaré l'avocat français de julian
assange antoine veil jean luc mélenchon
également a réagi je le cite y dit il a
qualifié d' ignoble la décision anglaise
d'expulser aux états unis assange pour
le leader de la france soumise il s'agit
d'un meurtre sous l'apparence sous des
apparences judiciaire on a ce qui laisse
faire at il déclaré pour rappel
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 10 décembre
qui est la journée internationale de
l'onu pour les droits de l'homme ce qui
donne ce qui laisse un goût très amer
vous l'imaginez pour les soutiens julian
assange c'est ce qu'a fait remarquer
d'ailleurs christine hart hanson le
rédacteur en chef de wikileaks je le
cite il dit à l'occasion de la journée
des droits de l'homme des nations unies
un tribunal britannique jette le
journalisme d'investigation dans les
ténèbres et continuent de torturer
julian assange a déclaré donc le
rédacteur en chef de wikileaks qui
assure que ce combat ne s'arrêtera pas
là néanmoins justement mrm quelle sera
la suite de cette saga judiciaire
alors la suite donc là les avocats
d'assange ont annoncé immédiatement
qu'ils allaient faire appel la justice
britannique va devoir à nouveau statuer
sur l'extradition
c'est elle autorise la défense de julian
assange pourra encore faire appel devant
la cour suprême du royaume uni et si là
encore l'extradition est confirmée bien
le dernier recours sera la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme à
strasbourg tout cela prendra encore
beaucoup de temps au minimum un an
l'avocat français d'assange antoine veil
a laissé entendre tout à l'heure qu'il y
aurait une demande de liberté
conditionnelle en attendant de nouvelles
étapes judiciaires mais vu les
précédents refus de dans ce domaine
enfin pour des libérations
conditionnelles
il est très difficile d'être optimiste
de ce point de vue et en attendant d'où
la naissance journalisme multi primé qui
avait reçu de très nombreux prix de
journalisme qui a révélé des crimes de
guerre et des crimes contre l'humanité
américain reste détenu dans une prison
de haute sécurité en grande bretagne
comme si c'était un terroriste meriem
merci un beau coup à devrait était avec
nous sur ce plateau rappel est
journaliste pour le site web de art
martial